there are roots to redemption in this
country that don't exist anywhere else
but Russia is the old world there's no
root for progosian to do a game show
there's zero root that's not how Russia
works that's not how it works you can't
go be the host of Wheel of Fortune after
you've tried to cool look at this
pagosian was spotted in a polo shirt and
mom jeans cutting a seemingly more mild
manner figure than in months Pat yeah
he's Gotta Die they're gonna kill him
are you nuts he's doing good Glam shots
in St Petersburg in a in a polo shirt
like I'm a famous guy now on the world
stage sorry I tried to overthrow the
government but listen
there's got to be equity in my brand no
isn't there equity in this brand